hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this past week has been one of the
most incredible of my time on YouTube
and it's gonna sound like a hell week
when I describe it because pretty much
every day was so densely packed and
frantic that it'll sound horrible but
just know that I've been happier than
I've been in a long time in all my time
on YouTube and probably my entire life
I've never been this busy and this
excited to work on stuff like we've been
doing this past week and let me just let
me set the scene for you I got to back
up a bit before I get dive into that as
many of you know Tyler has been helping
me out here and Tyler is a guy I've
known since the fourth grade I've known
him for years
we know each other too well like scary
well we get along that well and it's
just so good to have someone out here
because Tyler pushes me to be a better
person
Tyler pushes me to explore the ideas
that I wouldn't ordinarily do and and I
don't want to sing praises of Tyler and
inflate his ego here but he has been
such a good force in my life since he's
come out here that I can't help but be
so appreciative of him just taking the
risk and coming out here and Ethan as
well if some of you guys will go mad
like who's this blue haired guy that's
Ethan his YouTube channels crank
gameplays and he's also here helping me
make videos and this past week starting
on Sunday starting on Sunday we had this
idea to do disco discomfort and it just
spawned from this let's play that I did
where I was like hey we should go out
and we should dance with fans and we did
exactly that and it was so much fun like
it was so incredibly fun it was Suze
it's ridiculous how cool it was to go
out and see you guys and be there with
you and just be in the environment and
be like hey let's have some fun today
let's do something we never would have
done
and to see what the [ __ ] happens and it
was amazing
because we just kept doing it like the
whole week once we caught that spark
that one thing clicked in all of our
minds going like holy [ __ ] this is
amazing going out and being there with
you guys and doing these things with you
guys and just having fun and going out
and exploring new ideas and we didn't do
it in the best way we know that we
didn't plan it very well we didn't stack
it up on days and that's why there was
only one video a week this week and I'm
sorry about that that is gonna change
that is back in line and back on
schedule but it was just so absolutely
ah fire building it built it like that
spark that I always talk about the spark
of motivation and the spark of like oh
the spark of passion that one fire that
burns in your heart for what you wanted
to do and I want to make videos god I
love it
ah I can't help but be excited about it
because this week has drawn so much back
into myself and it's also made me
realize my shortcomings it's made me
realize that I've grown not lazy but
complacent in what I've been doing and
I'm really sorry about that and and I
owe you guys the apology because it was
an unseen thing you know I've talked
about before how things aren't what they
are but they're starting on the road to
become something and I felt like I was
walking down that path for a long time
and I was lost
like I've been lost because I've been
wandering without wondering where I was
and what I was doing and why I was doing
it and
this week I can't help but gush
- everybody that'll listen to me and now
it's you guys that are gonna have to
listen to me I can't help but gush about
every single thing I'm excited about and
how fun this is and how amazing it is to
do it and the response has been so good
I I can't describe how much it's touched
my heart to see people look at these
videos that we've been making over the
past we can go my god it reminds me of
the old markiplier and that is
absolutely heartwarming to hear and I'm
so happy that people can see the passion
that we put into this and see the energy
that we put into this and see the joy
that it brings to us and me and I'm just
happy and I could I could tell you the
details this week I could tell you that
over the past three days I've recorded
18 videos not because I have to because
I wanted to and over the past week we
went out and we recorded these videos
with fans and we got hours and hours of
footage and we were editing until
midnight or later every single night and
then getting up at 6:00 a.m. and going
out and doing it all over again and it's
that passion god it's that passion that
I had back in the beginning of my
channel when I first started doing
videos I was doing than every single
waking hour of the day because I loved
it because it felt like I had something
that was my own because I felt like I
could control something in my life and
my life at the time was spiraling out of
control and I think it's paralleled
right now
like my life was kind of spiraling out
of control and it wasn't until I let go
a feelings of anger and and hate it
wasn't till I let go of that which
bothered me and it wasn't till I let go
of these lofty unrealistic goals of who
I should be I came back to who I was and
who I wanted to be and that's so like
it's a feeling I can't describe in words
even though I'm shouting my words at you
trying to describe it uh but I just
wanted to let you guys know that there's
so much behind the scenes footage and
IIIi came in on a great screenshot here
it's just there was a lot of footage
that we just got in the car and what I
want to do uh what I want to do is I
want to make Monday vlogs come back
again markiplier Monday's if you want to
call them that but I want to bring these
vlogs back again and I want to recap and
talk about everything that's happened
over the week all the cool people that
we've met the places we've gone the
things we've done and the bloopers that
we've recorded all of it there's one
here I want to go do it right away
because I was watching through this and
it's just oh this is uh okay this is
during the UH deer man deer this during
Dearman it was such a beautiful day at
this park and what we did is we went
there Jesus Oh Oh God oh that's me oh
Jesus that's me I did not thought those
doctors over there then I looked at the
pants I'm like I should of course that's
me it's okay
subscribe - oh jeez oh jeez there we go
oh that guy was that guy was pretty shy
but he really came out of his shell
later towards the end of the day and it
was really cool to see because he was
shy at first because he's like oh my
gosh it's you but then it was just like
people it was just like he came out of
his shell out he was just really
comfortable and he had a lot of fun
we all had a lot of fun we all had so
much fun there and that's what really
made it special oh here it is okay I
found it get him get him
cuz it's literally what it boiled down
do it was oh Jesus I forgot about that
moment
Ethan panned away perfectly so it showed
me hey it showed me women pans back
right for the hit right on again what
cost was weird me like oh my god yeah we
it was just it was so much fun recording
with you guys this was just food this
was just one of the days that we did but
we did so much more stuff more than him
Ellen Ellen yes you had her chrome eyes
I do thank you for noticing that they're
very groovy they're groovy mutation ah
okay I want to talk about that moment
real quick because that was Ellen and
Ellen said later after we met in that
Park
she wrote a tumblr post and in it she
was touched by the fact that I noticed
her header a Croma eyes and
heterochromia your eye has two different
colors in it and it was just it was so
heartwarming to see because that little
detail meant so much to her and that
never would have happened if we had not
gone out to the park and tried to meet
these people and dance with them for no
other reason than just to dance with
them and that was so it was so
heartwarming because after that day it
was so I don't mean to freeze on this
frame up sorry and we literally just we
literally just danced with everyone that
showed up every time a new person showed
up we formed a dance circle and
literally just swarm them and then
eventually collaged it into a big ol
music video
- cool Patrol
door oh she was so nervous oh she was so
nervous but it's okay it's okay look at
this crowd oh yeah her parents were
waiting in the car
so we ran over to her parents and then
made them dance you ready to dance yeah
God okay I I could gush about that one
video for an hour but I'll try to like
wrap it up in just a few sentences it
was so fun it was the best experience
that I could have possibly gotten out of
that day it was so heartwarming to see
people come out of the woodwork drive
from like across town just to meet us in
a park and have a impromptu dance party
it was so heartwarming to see and when
we went back from that day and we went
back home and we started editing
immediately after that and we started
collaging things together we didn't know
how it was gonna turn out before we
filmed it but after we filmed it
we caught this spark that just could not
be stopped nothing was gonna get in the
way and that's part of the reason why we
only did one video day because we
literally just sprinted forward and were
like we're gonna [ __ ] do this
I don't care what it takes we want to do
it so the next thing we did was we had
this idea and we have this turkey
costume that was gonna be like hey we
wanted to do this kind of like thing
saying hey give Thanksgiving its room
crisp it's not Christmas yet it's not
December or at least wait till after
Thanksgiving and then it was just oh man
it turned out so well and it was we
found this rhythm with the musical
intros and it was just so cool god I
loved it I loved every part of it I kept
gushing to absolutely everybody that
would listen to me
about how much I loved it and I'm still
doing it oh god I just want everyone to
know about my new inside pocket it's
called my butthole
why am i laughing at myself that's the
most narcissistic thing that I could
possibly do it's so it's so good to see
oh no it's so good to see the important
thing the nose oh it's so good to see
this it's so good to experience this
because what we went through this past
week is by any definition life-changing
look literally I mean that it's changed
my life because I feel like I was on the
wrong path I really do and I'm sorry
about that because it's it's not numbers
that define me it's not numbers that
define this channel and it's not numbers
that define the community I'm very
fortunate and I am eternally grateful
that 15 million people thought my videos
were worth subscribing to and I'm always
going to be grateful for that but I fear
that I was growing complacent in those
numbers I was looking at those numbers
and I was going that's good enough I've
done enough I can rest this is okay
that's not true at all I grew lazy in my
confidence of what I had that I allowed
myself to lose sight of the final goal
and the final goal is to be the best
youtuber that I can be maybe I'll never
be the best youtuber ever but that
doesn't mean that I shouldn't keep
trying every single day as hard as I can
to be better not only for my own sake
but for you guys as well
because you guys are everything to this
channel you guys are absolutely
everything to who we as youtubers are
and who I define myself as a person I
really mean that honestly and truly like
I define myself by the community that
I've built and if I let my community go
to stray
I go astray that I have failed so
there's so much other footage here that
we could go through from this past week
and this was just one week like in one
week we've managed to create so many
memories have so many laughs meet so
many of you guys and that was just one
week I can't describe how great it is to
feel that fire burning in my heart again
and to have that passion back for making
videos and surprising you every day with
cool new interesting things and I can
only thank my friends and my family and
most of all you guys for never losing
hope in me I don't know what I did to
deserve so many people that steadfastly
believe in what I do I'm committed again
more than ever more than ever I'm so
excited for the future so like I said
we'll be back on normal schedule very
soon eight and twelve everyday eight AMS
will be long plays and twelve a.m. 12
p.m. noon also known as will be
something special and I think you're
gonna like it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
you